[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to a very special
quarantine episode of life is short i'm
starting to think they're not each
special life could be a dream sweetheart
they're special okay okay and i'm your
host justin long and with me as always
is my um
very common not common the rapper
have you ever been compared to common
not that i've heard but i'm sure people
have done it behind my back
the rapper yeah yeah i'm sure you get
that i've got some common vibes
you have i i hate to say this because
it's so insulting but you're a commoner
to me no
but there's there's very little common
denominator between you two common ones
um you are probably you're probably more
often you're so excited about your joke
yeah you spazzed on it
common denominator between you two
that'll serve that'll learn me
um what will if you if you had to say
some things i had in common with
comments what would they be if you had
to say oh you both have very uh uh deep
voice nice voices okay that's good okay
um you
you're both multi-talented you're good
with words
yes he's better at putting them together
in a rhyming fashion fine okay
[Laughter]
um i bet i'm better at ping pong
probably all right let's see i'll have a
who's right who's oh you're gonna
comment i'll lose that all day long
you're from
from the shorties and the shorty's
boyfriends so welcome to a very special
edition of well now you're over selling
how special it is okay well that's what
you judged me for this is our
i want to say this is our
ninth quarantine
i think eight or nine i could be wrong
um but but who's counting this has
become the new normal yeah so it's nice
i guess we have to stop calling it a
quarantine because that uh that denotes
something different
now it's time for maybe we should just
start saying a midweek episode yeah but
you don't once you stop calling it a
quarantine then and and referring to it
as just the new normal i think there's
something a little um psychologically
demoralizing about that yeah you want to
still say that this is not normal life
yeah that's true and i want to ask dr
kessler when we check in with him about
that but we just heard that la is going
to they're continuing their lockdown for
the next three months i'm sure you
already all know that so we wonder what
that's going to mean for other parts of
the country uh and how that's going to
affect travel to other to those parts of
the country and are people going to be
leaving la now to you know wonder well
getting to something
much more important than that really
quickly um
today marks our one year anniversary of
doing life short of of the show first
episode of the show coming out i just
got it was may 13th of last year and
we're recording this today is may 13th i
don't know when it's going to come out
maybe a couple days from now but yeah
this is the one year that's cool so
happy one year anniversary you too
thanks
uh that's exciting that's really nice uh
i can't believe we made it a year last
night we did a instagram live
uh experience what do you call it live
uh
live chat chat yeah
and it was the first one it was really
funny my what your hair is just like
standing straight up my mustache hair no
do you feel that your head hair oh yeah
it's like a tough maggie just cut it oh
did i tell you that it's funny it's so
funny because it looks like a bird his
girlfriend is really obsessed with birds
it's safe to say she should be so funny
if she yeah obsessed is a good word
she's very intimate she's into birth
yeah
yeah what if she started slowly turning
me into a bird what is that that's
that's a movie oh well it's a little
like
i hate to be self-referential but i did
a movie like that it is a tusk that's
right yeah that's right but it's like
something else too right i'm gonna look
up what is
what is a bird lover called
ornithile
oh maybe
uh she is that whatever ornithologist is
someone who studies
someone who who does this is called a
bird oh
bird watcher now it doesn't say the
scientific study of birds called
ornithology people who study birds as a
professional ornithologist
but it doesn't say oh yeah or ornith
ornithophile ornithophile or nithiphile
a person it sounds like you have
something to give a lisp
so ornistophile no ornithophile that's
how you say it uh i it's got it's
something other than tusk isn't it isn't
there another movie like that it's not
it's a little frankenstein-y i guess
yeah where she's slowly that's kind of a
fun idea for
like a
that's a good idea for him or is it not
it's like a kevin smith or is it just us
that's right
i can't believe
if it is just tusk that's we should stop
smoking weed or eating weed i haven't
been smoking it yeah it is very tough to
uh it's funny she's really into so we
have birds all over the
all over the property so getting back
this instagram live we did it last night
and we appreciate the people who
did watch and listen
um
listening and asking good questions
it was overwhelming i would say only
because
it was going upstairs if you're not used
to doing them i think the impulse is to
try to answer every single question and
when they come so quickly yes it's
impossible to give any real time to any
single question you can only really
answer yes no questions because it's
like without short
changing some or without not getting to
certain questions
i think you have to just pick and choose
and and not feel guilty for missing
certain ones yeah so it's not something
that you should maybe do well you were
saying yeah you were saying it's a
difficult thing for guilt-ridden people
who want
to appease everyone it's a difficult
thing for them to do maybe impossible
impossible yeah because unless you're
like the micro machine man and you just
processed things you'd like the mind of
uh carl sagan not only would you have to
process it quickly you'd have to
speak quickly yeah that's well that's
right the combination and who wants to
hear that
be entertaining
but then it'd be hard for the people
listening to it exactly yeah well so
sorry about that well we had fun but uh
sorry if we seemed uh on
hyper speed
yeah it was fun though um
what else uh what other things well i
mean this is what other housekeeping
things should go god i hate that so much
well people were asking about grandma
jody she's doing really well actually
and we are
god i mean in terms of our own
quarantine television watching we're
just so into the last dance i know it's
broken record now at this point
we're talking about it too much but if
you haven't seen it you really shouldn't
if you have seen it god i want to talk
to all of you about it because i used so
good i used to
loathe michael jackson michael jackson
writing i used to really load michael
jordan when i was a kid because he broke
my heart so many times as a knicks fan
and
i mean i obviously recognized that he
was an amazing player but i never liked
him because he he was like the enemy to
me growing up
but now watching the series i not only
do i like him
uh i have such a different opinion of
him now but i i think he's like the
coolest person who's ever lived
it's hard to imagine somebody being
cooler and even his flaws and the way he
owns them and struggles with them he is
just so
impressive they're you know physically
obviously i was going to say also on
just a very superficial level the way he
looks the way he walks he has a certain
way like a swagger about the way he runs
see he had swag i mean like before i
even knew was that a term back then i
guess it was in the 90s i remember there
were kids who would imitate the way he
moved oh definitely a kid in our
neighborhood john callahan was the who
was the best he was like the michael
jordan of our neighborhood yeah yeah he
was really cool in our neighborhood and
and he would not only imitate him on the
basketball court uh but but just in yeah
the way he walked around normally in the
way he
moved carried himself i think it was
very choreographing jordan sort of walks
like he has a slight injury all the time
you know he has yeah he is like kind of
a limp it's like is that swagger it's
swagger i'm telling you that's what
swagger is
uh who's that who's that
leslie jordan is it i guess it is leslie
did one today was so funny he did a
video today about going to the dentist
and they made him wear all these things
all the the masks and everything he said
is that's the first time i've been
excited about going to the dentist i
never thought i'd get excited i'm
butchering his story um
yeah god it's good it's funny to go from
jordan to leslie jordan michael jordan
is a leslie jordan is that what made you
think of him oh maybe maybe i don't know
i don't maybe god they're such different
jordans
yeah so
i like them both so much too that's just
shows you they're both incredible
it shows you the spectrum of um but an
appealing person one couldn't do what
the other does at all
that's a good question who would be more
capable of
of uh being like the other one you know
in a more effective way would you say oh
that would i crushed it
i think it's easy actually uh that that
michael would be better at being leslie
yeah because michael
not only does he have acting experience
with he hosted snl he yeah space jam
yeah
uh but he's he's got a personality you
know he can
yeah he could probably turn it on yeah
whereas i don't think leslie jordan
could
play against gary payton in game six of
the nba finals
it's so great how he talks about gary
payton he he even when he
oh yeah the glove he even says his
nickname dismissively and like
he's making fun of his nickname but
without being shitty without being like
overtly shitty you know
he's so [ __ ] impressive so we've been
watching that we uh we did that we did a
show oh yeah it was on i guess if you
hear this on friday which is likely it
was on last night
yeah but now you can find things it's
funny i guess so yeah i guess it doesn't
matter it's old-fashioned now i know to
be like oh and there's no you're right i
just dated myself tb schedule yeah but
it aired uh thursday night
on fox and it was a show called
celebrity watch party which is a new
it's the second episode of the show
that's very popular overseas but it's
new to america i think and it's
basically
uh
in
in this iteration in the american
iteration at least it's celebrities and
their friends or family
watching tv yeah different things on tv
your dream job it's like new shows um
prime time shows yeah they showed us all
these different i think they're all
different fox shows sports i think so
all sports thing so so you watch
different segments of these shows and
you
like talk through it basically you hang
out and you talk so we got
paid to watch tv and talk about it yeah
you know we'll see we'll see how it uh
turned out we'll find out tomorrow night
it was fun it definitely was fun
uh i do know that um but there were a
lot of shows that we hadn't seen before
like 9-1-1 the show 9-1-1 i've never
seen that uh the one about the venom
where they're just there's a show what's
that called uh i forgot it's basically
so many of them it's basically um these
these two guys they're like thrill
seekers but they're also as it turns out
doing it for science where they if they
they voluntarily get bitten by venomous
creatures it's [ __ ] crazy
uh the one we saw got bit by a
reticulated python uh which
looked very painful and
yeah so there's that it was fun it was
fun it was strange we're doing it again
this weekend so more to report yeah more
vague things um
anyway
what else let's check in with dave yeah
let's call dr dave okay dave kessler
here we here we go
checking in with dr dave his
this is something funny happened with
his kids uh
she's supposed to be the lead in her
fifth grade
how are you
oh dave
hi hi
uh i don't know if you want to talk
about this but i was just reading your
text to christian and um
oh i can hear in the background i was uh
about to say that your daughter was
supposed to be the lead in her fifth
grade play oh
yeah should we not talk about that um i
mean well
i will have her listen to it
it's her turn to talk right maybe we'll
skip her this week i'll check in with
her next week but no no i'd rather talk
to her talk about how devastated she is
that's not fun
yeah we don't want to talk about
devastating she is i thought maybe she
could get together with uh jerry's kids
and they could do something uh better
than been hiking in place i mean isn't
that
well i mean the whole fifth grade thing
you know
for so many i mean fifth grade probably
ever you know every it's like which is
the most momentous occasion everyone
thinks their own thing is college
graduations and right med school
graduation right before a fifth grader
yeah
for fifth grader this was big she could
not wait till middle school in part
because she thinks that's when she's
getting a phone but i'm still uh i'm
still pushing for 12. oh that's smart
yeah wow that's weird that's not
something we obviously went through when
we were kids uh but that must be weird
weird i would hold out as long as
possible i know yeah it must be tough
because all the kids must have them
yeah it's tough actually um
you know small psa i i feel like um
there's an uptick i don't know if
there's an uptick but but certainly
something i'm aware of now is like the
whole you know the whole cyber bullying
thing yeah with kids being like so
online now
uh for their schooling um like you know
i i've been i in the er too i've been
seeing people um
with you know with mental health
consequences from that still going on um
you know you know
and that's a well-known thing but um
yeah make sure you check in on your kids
if you have them and
uh talk to them about this for me my
middle one you know didn't was not she
was nowhere near being allowed to be
online and now they figure out how to
chat and google docs and of course you
know the older one taught her how to do
that and so oh [ __ ]
so much more to look out for oh i bet
you well you know it's funny jerry
mentioned that on last quarantine
episode he said his kids were having a
hard time with with bullying oh online
oh you know yeah i think i'm up to that
part i haven't finished uh the episode
yet
uh
hey dave how um how is it going this
week how are um things on the front line
how are things progressing
p you know pediatrics is is um
getting quite active in this story now i
think we talked a little bit about it
but it's really
um
this this entity you know is really uh
on the rise and uh we're
you know seeking to understand it um i i
guess i'm being vague for those who
maybe haven't been following the news
there's um you know a new illness a
syndrome i'll call it uh in in children
that we're seeing that we think is
related to covet just from the pure
spike in numbers and and you know
statistically speaking
um you know it's probably correlated
with that and um i think that's got a
lot of parents very concerned dave i'm
sorry i didn't know that i've been i
guess out of touch with that
i didn't even i didn't heard that oh i
know that yeah yeah i forget whether we
talked about it or not no we definitely
didn't
um oh so it's so it's a similar co with
similar symptoms as covid oh so no this
is actually it's similar to some other
diseases we've seen
in particular one called kawasaki
although it's it's it's definitely not
the same entity it may be related we
won't know really for sure until we get
more information i mean in many kawasaki
itself um
in part is a little bit enigmatic there
are some theories around it so i don't
know some of us are affectionately
calling it kovasaki but um but you know
the official term there's some debates
actually over what to call it they're
calling it either pmis which is
pediatric multi-inflammatory syndrome
um or uh msis which is multi-system
inflammatory so i'm maybe i'm messing
this up now we're still debating over
that what we call it well was it was was
it born in japan
um no it wasn't actually um some of the
first cases were reported in the uk at
around the same time um we had it here i
actually think i had
one of our very first cases in in our in
our center
um and um
the department of health has been
collecting reports i think we're we're
up to 700 in the country now
wow god another one wait so how is it
manifesting it what are the
is it as deadly as kobe well well what's
it seems to be um like an immune
reaction or an inflammatory response to
having had the virus um there are many
versions of this and various you know uh
diseases and pediatrics and adults that
we see that are similar
but but this is you know for the best of
our knowledge it seems like
a child had or was exposed to covid you
know several weeks or a month ago
and then now their body
um reacts um
to having had that so they're not
currently infected most of these
children are some of them are positive
but most are not acutely positive
for the virus but their blood serology
is showing that they had been exposed so
they have some immunity to it um and
then you know the working theories that
that immunity sort of you know as it
does sometimes in their autoimmune
disease may be going wild and attacking
normal cells so we're seeing diffuse
involvement the most worrisome is
probably the cardiac involvement in
children who are having heart failure or
heart problems are going into shock
and we've had a couple of deaths around
the city already
um so you know this is probably why i
didn't bring it up because i think the
media is really having parents uh
worried about this they're
sensationalizing it yeah it's a scary
thing i mean still still it's a very low
number of children getting this and the
good news is i have to say other than
those reported deaths which are tragic
um even kids who are very very sick
coming into the hospital um if they're
coming in soon enough you know generally
they're they're leaving the hospital
much better and um resolved after a
short course of some treatment and
typically steroids steroids or um
something called ivig and so to dispel
any of the worries that parents might
have what are some of the symptoms and
when should parents uh bring their kids
in
yeah
um
and i'm not saying people shouldn't you
know have concern but but uh it's to
look out for those same severe symptoms
we've talked about before
um
first of all
nearly everyone with this syndrome has
fever
um as part of the body's sort of
inflammatory response children have
usually high fever 104 105 degrees
fahrenheit
and that fever is going to persist so
what we're not sure about yet is what to
tell people in terms of when to come in
with kawasaki's disease there was
evidence that you know first of all we
didn't really start calling it kawasaki
until you're at least five days of fever
um and then um you know we start looking
for things and there's evidence that if
you treat it in under 10 days you know
you sort of do well we don't know enough
about this disease to know when so i
would i would probably urge an earlier
threshold if you're having very high
fevers your child
and you're having
evidence of other system involvement
because it's a system it's a systemic
disease so that means um vomiting and
diarrhea like abdominal pain it has been
a very common manifestation we've seen
with this
um and
chest pain or shortness of breath
a rash a lot of children have a rash a
generalized rash or different types of
rashes
um and and pink eye actually goes with a
lot of cases as well so it's weird you
know okay not actually pink guy but
conjunctive that's weird i know three
um elderly people
grandparents of friends of mine who have
all tested positive and uh and none of
them show any symptoms
yeah i've been hearing that and dave
when it comes to that in terms of the
antibodies would would your body not
produce as many or any antibodies if uh
there's no
need for it to if it didn't exist in
your body in a in a if your body didn't
have a reaction you weren't affected
physically by it right
i i get a sense like you're trying to
see if you have more antibodies than
christian at this point yes it's well
everything is a company we have a lot of
money writing on this
yeah yeah no that's an excellent
question i there was just actually i
haven't fully read it there have been a
lot of theories about it there was just
a paper that came out yesterday
um that was sort of trying to look at
the different rates of you know the
immune
response in people
um i i didn't i don't recall it being
framed in context of what your symptoms
were but in general that's that's not um
you know the main factor in your
immunity um think about a vaccine
some people get a vaccine and uh you
know they feel achy and they have a
fever afterwards and that's you know
people sometimes say oh i got i got the
flu because i got the flu vaccine that's
not true at all what's happening is that
when you feel achy and uh and have low
grade fevers and stuff like that that's
more to do with your own body's immune
response it's actually in the context of
a vaccine usually a good thing oh um but
some people get a vaccine right they
have none of those symptoms at all but
they're still building immunity so this
just has more to do with the individual
and how they mount their immune response
and um and then the inflammatory cascade
associated with it there's there's
literally like since i graduated med
school there have been so many different
more uh uh you know molecules in this
pathway of inflammation they've
identified and you've probably heard it
in reference to covid because we talk
about cytokine storm or inflammatory
cascade and so um
you know that's a general term for what
turns out to be many of any very
specific pathways in which the body can
create this inflammation yes i heard
about it
yeah that that cytokin would say it
again cytokine storm cytokine storm yes
yes so it's like some of the drugs that
you might have heard of like they're
specifically targeting you know and and
we test like the interleukin-6 is one of
them so you know there's many
interleukins uh that's mr number six and
um you know text testing the levels of
each of these um you know there are
different disease processes associated
and this one uh and with kova that one
particular tends to be low and so that
led to some of the thought process
between some of the anti-ill il-6 you
know treatments that they're looking at
um and um yeah so that they they you
know again we we and look i'm a
generalist right i'm not an expert in
immunology i'm not an expert in in those
drugs um part of the job in er is to
sort of like know a little bit about
everything and try to put together the
puzzle
um you know early on but but the
scientists looking at this um
are really in the weeds in the details
of trying to figure out the best ways to
to address that that cytokine storm oh
okay well we'll keep we'll keep checking
in with you then and uh we'll we'll see
how how much closer um i just heard of
it in the context of the spanish flu uh
i i lost you at il6 right yeah six yeah
no no i was actually um i we we have to
go because we have uh
but um i just wanted to mention some of
you uh dave i'm gonna bug you to make a
video to help us with this video a bunch
of actors are putting together to raise
money for a group called
fuelfrontlines.com it's um a friend of
our sam pennix he he uh has this company
called everyman espresso it's in the
lobby the classic stage company theater
on 13th street and third avenue and they
are um and if and if you or any of your
healthcare workers if you want to tell
them they can go to fuel frontlines.com
and it allows them to request a free
coffee and a snack delivery because uh
for their hospital and it's it's really
taken off uh we've been hearing that
that was
uh difficult they were having difficulty
just getting food because a lot of the
you know obviously restaurants and shops
were shut down a lot of the bodegas were
shut down so
um that's something we're going to ask
you to help us out with but um
sure you can
spread that around fuelfrontlines.com
fuelfrontlines.com all right i'll plug
it on my next episode okay okay thanks
dave um and thanks so much i tell your
daughter we're uh our
we're sorry she couldn't be in the play
but um i'm not gonna tell her that
because okay we're just not we're not
talking about okay all right
you know well i was really hoping they'd
be one of those you know like like zoom
plays at least you know like yeah
you look forward all throughout
elementary school right yeah and and
finally she got like the lead in this
place her first
part you know was that uh angels in
america
it was uh it was it was alice in
wonderland but
whichever like whichever jabberwocky
version i'm not sure yeah um oh that's a
shame well maybe they could do like ar
gurney's love letters or something do
monologues on zoom
yeah i'm gonna have to set up something
hilarious
but
um well
thanks dave anytime uh we'll check in uh
a couple days thanks buddy thanks dave
all right great
take care okay good luck this week
all right youtube thanks for everything
dave
uh wow well that's i'm glad i brought it
up it's basically i should go to the
people who are running this organization
it sounds like they have a lot uh food
which is good yeah it's a great thing
but maybe this charity that you're doing
can pivot to exactly food banks or
something yeah that's a good idea okay
um well we i also didn't mean to be
offensive when i asked who was born in
japan because it sounds i know japanese
but it's probably
uh like kawasaki like cci instead of
you know
oh yeah like k.i remember the kawasaki
one man bam
no it was like a synthetic cow a sake
one man bam remember there's still no no
you can keep singing all right kyle
wasaki wanna do a band don't have
friends do it on your synthesizer that's
the
jam life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge-watching
low-budget made-for-tv holiday movies
the all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wonder plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
okay okay um well we uh unfortunately we
ran out of time for jerry i'm just
kidding uh we haven't heard back from
jerry
so uh we'll check in again next week
with jerry or attempt to and right now
uh let's do a couple would you rather
all right first let us do a letter oh
okay sorry sorry
um do you mind if i read it please okay
hello justin and christian again
i just listened to your quarantine
check-in number five in which you read
my letter shown below
thanks so much for reading my letter to
your audience on this episode you
mentioned that you would both like some
of my origami cranes oh yeah of course
the origami i would be honored to send
some to both of you but could not find a
mailing address on your website please
let me know where to send the cranes how
many you would like and if you have any
color preference i'm attaching a photo
of me with a 1 000 colorful cranes so
you can see all the colors that are
available yes i also listened to
quarantine checking number six in which
you read a letter from another listener
who had an idea about what i should do
with a thousand wow true shorty
i appreciate the suggestion your
listener offered but decided to share my
origami cranes with family and friends
rather than putting them up for auction
yeah to date i've mailed out more than
275 letters to family and friends whoa
includes a lot of family and friends i
know in closing a total of 700 cranes oh
my the responses i have received are
very heartwarming and i'm very gratified
that my cranes have touched so many
people in very meaningful and
significant ways
by the way in my original email to you
that included information about my
father i forgot to mention that steven
spielberg is my third cousin on my dad's
side of the family weird specifically
steven and i share the same great great
grandparents wow mine from my father's
side and his from his mother's side
just an interesting side note i thought
you might enjoy yeah i'm looking forward
to enjoy that i'm looking forward to
getting your mailing address so that i
can send some cranes to both of you
thanks again for reading my letter and
sharing my mission with your audience
take care stay well and stay safe bob
this is what bob and his cranes look
like oh my god first of all bob is a
very handsome man he is he's a little
john mahoney vibe yeah
a little a little jonathan price maybe
in there uh fairy yeah silver haired
those are cool gentlemen i wish we could
show these yeah well it's just a huge so
bob is sitting indian style and
presenting uh with his open palms a huge
in front of him laid out is just a big
pile of
colorful origami crayons it's really
cool um we we know uh i wonder who his
so he's what he's somehow related to
steven spielberg yeah that's cool i'm
not at all related to steven spielberg
yeah a friend of ours is steven
spielberg's daughter okay let's read a
couple thanks bob that's right yeah so
cool about it and we will get you our uh
i would love a couple cranes yeah i
can't believe he has that many friends
and family i'm just impressed by that
too well maybe it's more family than
friends still i mean that's crazy i
would say it's much more impressive if
it's more friendly than family that's
true because then he's actually
cultivated all these relationships yeah
instead of just being born into this big
family being yeah being related to
people who have a lot of sex knowing bob
i think it's more friends than family oh
you oh really yeah yeah yeah
yeah you'll be able to cultivate
friendship doesn't seem like you'd run
into them at like a like a tiki
kind of bar in key west or something or
in like sarasota yeah uh all right here
we go
this one would you rather ready yes
this is from kate b
hi justin christian i love and so
greatly appreciate your podcast it helps
me to enjoy my commutes to the office
before the quarantine and now pleasantly
pass the time during quarantine i'm 25
weeks pregnant with my third son and
when i'm not stressing about kovid 19
the pregnancy my full-time job or life
in general i find myself laughing out
loud hours after i listen to your most
recent podcast would you rather
suggestions
would you rather have shirley temple
style curls
or a joe exotic type mullet forever oh
that's a good one okay surely let me
imagine those for a second
imagine you were surely temple girls or
um
i think
god i think that you know what i think
i'd say the mullet
really show exotic mullet because
um
i i i think in a weird way it might look
less ridiculous it'd certainly be easier
to take care of oh that's true you know
i i was leaning towards the shirley
temple because
uh you were like so crazy i would i'd
look here's the thing i would look crazy
either way uh i think less crazy is it
with did show exotics see i think i'd
look less crazy with shirley temple
because her color her hair color is
slightly more my color than joe exotics
platinum weird oh right
the color would be weird oh i forgot
about against my skin tone
and the mullet would be i think i would
go shirley temple and really lean into
it and really embrace how do you lean
into it and start singing her songs no
no no but do you know any of her songs
i'm a good ship
but you know in general i think guys
with
guys big guys with big curly hair don't
think to kind of
embrace it in a fun way yeah you tend to
be more confident it might make you more
bouncy and big exactly yeah
it would put some bounce in your step so
i'm going shirley temple that's a good
question though okay um second question
would you rather marry joe exotic or doc
antle
oh god in heaven that's a torah i mean
it's a good question but uh mine i know
mine oh wait um
all right on the count of three after
you have yours we'll do it okay one two
three
here's why here's what i think because
doesn't he have like seven or eight
wives yeah okay so you wouldn't have to
spend a shuffle yes yeah you could fade
into the background of his wives a
little bit more you wouldn't have to
spend as much time with him
he
he seems a little more tender
and
gross i just imagine i just had a visual
of you guys spooning and uh also softer
he's bigger he's less into drugs that's
what i was gonna say he's he's less
messy and i think i think less dangerous
less
less um joe exotic would turn you he
would like he'd forced to apply you with
drugs to the to the point where you i
mean that's what that's just i just
think he's more unstable yeah i think i
mean who knows for sure but you know i
think joe exotic is a really real sick
[ __ ] and i i i think they're both sick
[ __ ] i think but yeah see doc antle
another argument for
picking him is that
i have a feeling
i just pictured you in his like harem
no and it's like group where you have to
like hang out with her you have to go to
like i'm like it's like being part of
the mansion yeah yeah only
i wonder if they all have to go to like
because he has to go probably functions
and stuff and like cocktail but i wonder
if they all have to go parties or like i
don't know like part like social
gatherings
uh but ci super bowl parties i think
it's much more likely that doc antle
would get sick of me before
uh joe exotic would get sick of me i
think i i think joe exotic would would
be
um
potentially
much more obsessed with me in every way
than doc antler so i think the
relationship would
if it was ever hot and heavy i think it
would fade
much faster with doc antle
yeah i guess so okay okay they're both
very possessive and all you really like
corrupt people all right number three
would you rather live in the [ __ ]
sandwich costume
or the asked me about my wiener costume
for one year oh that's a good this is a
reference to accepted yeah where
christian played the [ __ ] sandwich
mascot and jonah hill
uh
played or he he wore the wiener custom
we were on very similar paths at one
point in life
yeah you were both you turned down the
role in um wolf of wall street
[Laughter]
uh i would say the [ __ ] sandwich pretty
easily well but then you have to wear
this stuff all over your face and what
if you just wanted to take it off for a
breather exactly well i'd want to have
this [ __ ] on my face because then i'm
more hidden
yeah but then you have uh you know
you've browned stuff all over your face
yeah brown stuff all over your body
no joan i didn't wear face makeup in
that no i'm saying for the [ __ ] sandwich
guys
oh yeah so why would you want this oh
you're saying i want to be more covered
up
during this year oh i'm not as
recognizable whereas if i was wearing a
big hot dog costume with my whole face
showing yeah not only would my whole
face be showing but the hot dog itself
is much more recognizable as a weird
thing so i think i would draw more
attention i don't know because the [ __ ]
costume was that sandwiches pretty big
it was like a big it was a flat big they
were similar size yeah i mean it's i
would tell you they're similar but i
would take the one that covers my face
more yeah
and the one that i have a personal um
connection to it'd be tough either way
it'd be tough um okay we are sorry we're
speeding we have to talk to uh charlie
day very soon our name drop our friend
charlie charlie
why are you so late is that you have
time that was good we have time for one
more would you rather this week um we
did not leave enough time for this
okay and that's without jerry i know i
know
that's without jerry okay uh okay let's
do this one but
um
uh
this is from tara a
hi justin and christian first i just
want to say thank you so much for your
podcast it makes waking up every tuesday
worthwhile and i can honestly say that
out of all the podcasts i regularly
listen to yours is my favorite very
regularly yours is my favorite the
guests you bring on are so real and
relatable and you've given me so many
new tv shows and movies to watch i
listened to the maggie q episode on a
walk and immediately came home and
started the plot the pilot of nikita oh
whoa i'd also like to tell maggie's
listening i'd also like to quickly say
that i appreciate all the awareness that
you guys bring about mental health and
self-care i'm a current doctoral student
in clinical psychology and as a future
therapist we definitely need more people
like you talking about how important
getting help and talking to other people
is good now yeah congratulations now for
a would you rather yes would you rather
have to yell your brother's name
every time you orgasm during sex oh my
god that's so good
or
oh my god
hey
justin
that's how you orgasm
or have to bring your brother with you
on every date you ever had for the rest
of your life well i mean lately
i've been going on most due dates
in case you try to use logistics you
stay single forever and you have sex
once a week okay all right thank you for
the specifics you have a good one have a
good one guys you can tell she's a
doctoral student because she included
some important specific um details ah
let's see god that's a such a good one
okay
you come on every date
come on you don't come on everything i
know
okay
you
i bring you on every date that i go on
i'm imagining myself go on a lot of days
i'm single for life i've been on a date
i know but um imagine yourself single
for life you have to get in the head
space okay and then imagine yourself
having sex once a week right that's it
okay um
see either way here's the deal either
way i tell
either way you have to explain to your
partner what's happening so i would tell
you you can't just shock someone by
yelling at guy's name during sex nor can
you just show up with a guy who looks
like you on a date right but that but
maybe that's part of the hypothetic
let's say i'm tara didn't specify but
let's say that that's part of it is
you can't well look after it happens the
first time assuming it's with the same
person that you're having sex with and
going on dates with
but why assume that i mean uh well
you're single for life so you never get
i would rather sh i can't believe i'm
saying this but i i i like when you come
on i like having another person on a
date i think it's an easier way to meet
somebody right um and so that's nice i
think that's maybe not every date but um
i'd still pick that one i think then
yelling cause then it's like i wouldn't
look forward to sex as much knowing that
at the height of sex i'd like the climax
i would be yelling your name out or you
would just get used to that being a
little chore you have during sex a chore
it's more than a chore it's it would
demand that i didn't start thinking
about it no you wouldn't sure i would
i'm yelling your name i don't christian
i don't think so you're an actor you can
tune things out not if i knew it i would
that would just
or my partner wouldn't be able to that's
a different question okay but i think
you i'm a very generous i i think you
would be able to
um
uh disassociate my name from my body
let's say it would just be a thing you
had to say you know what's funny is that
i don't often i rarely use your name
anyway
christian i don't call you by your name
a lot yeah you've been calling me hoe
lately that oh that's another thing
michael jordan does that um
yeah he calls guys hope you can get away
with it because it's
not in any way derogatory to
well i don't know it is oh i guess it is
it is yeah i shouldn't have said that
i'm not i'm not going to start calling
you ho in neither my home
uh
no we can't say that we don't know
there's so many things we can't do that
michael jordan can get away with
i don't have a uh like
i don't have a lot of
dating i don't think in my future let's
say that i am single which i don't want
to be a planet i'm picturing maggie
listening to this i know but let's say
like for for the sake of the
hypothetical i'm single right yeah
as a single person i don't enjoy the
process of dating very much oh yeah so i
don't anticipate he's going on so many
dates and
so if i were to go on a date i would
like to have you along because it
makes it easier yeah i think so i'd
rather do that i know it'd be weird and
yeah i'm sure a lot of women would be
like i'm confused but really turned off
by me well yeah i'm like oh by the way
my brother's especially if it's like the
third or fourth date it's like okay the
first time is like that's one thing
you're getting to know somebody and
uh yeah the prospect of going on dates
though is here's the problem though
you're funny so i would be it would be
like the jordan
where i would feel like george and i
would have to tell you yeah don't be
less entertaining yeah so i didn't look
back that's nice to say
i think you you would look but i think
our sense of humor i think the way we
joke around is we would elevate one
another maybe maybe but it might be
annoying it would be annoying for a
woman on a date with us
now it sounds like we would just be
performing material exactly
yeah also we have a similar sense of
humor but you tend to be quicker and
faster than me and i i bet you're better
on dates than i am oh you think probably
i would guess if i don't know it really
has been so long now i'm picturing that
seinfeld episode that's so funny when he
goes it's one of the best moments when
he's like you have to be so funny am i
being funny now is this funny it's funny
it's funny
it's a little funny
you cannot not be funny
am i being funny now a little bit
yes
uh okay that's a good one though that's
really good
i i would say the date one i would even
though i i also think that if i were to
scream justin
then i think it would be something i'd
get used to honestly i guess so you'd
disappear it would become part of yeah
you know the deal yeah oh my god just
two and i would screaming anything is
would as a would be weird i know i you
know you can't ask it's why would you
know what it is this hypothetical is not
about me because i think in both cases
i'd be fine with it yeah it's a it's
about the other person and i can't say
because
i think it depends on who i'm going on a
date with how depends on who i'm into
yeah it's just it's hard because sex is
such a specific thing it's such an
intimate if it was up to me i would say
the date one all right what if you had
to scream something at when you orgasmed
if you had to yell something what what
would you want to yell
oh i would i would pick something very
generic yeah like yes yes yeah
do it or oh oh oh
not in pain oh oh
well it has been a while
okay all right well that's a great time
to end um uh this is gonna be a tough
pivot but uh oh [ __ ] we're gonna be late
for sure okay uh dave uh dr dave just
sent us this uh website that i wanna
read is if you wanna donate to food
which is now uh as he mentioned going to
food banks which are
in desperate need uh go to
gratifood g r a t
g-r-a-t-i-f-o-o-d-n-y-c
dot org gratified
nyc.org um okay thanks
okay
thanks to what's your favorite character
in the hobbit orc
thanks to dr dave and thanks to the
spirit of jerry o'connell he seems to be
here i felt him in this room too me too
uh and i didn't snicker as much this
week that's true
and thank you for listening for a year
yeah thanks for joining our instagram a
lot of people
did this last time enough yeah it's all
right let's and thanks to anita let's
not mention it again until the two year
anniversary okay all right okay so uh
that's it thanks everyone thanks for
listening uh god i've gotten after a
year i still haven't gotten good at
ending these things you're not good at
starting or ending no but you're great
in the middle oh thanks okay uh well um
thanks everyone for listening to hear
from us on tuesday yes who is it or
should we make a surprise make it a
surprise oh fun okay and uh do you want
to do the credits
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
here we go life is short is hosted by me
justin long it's also hosted by
you
christian long he also produces it along
with megan monaco and senior producer
michelle mieshlands audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive producers are
marshall
[Music]
louie and hernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
[Music]
you